und über die aktuelle Situation in der
Ukraine kann ich nun sprechen mit
basilikolot in Kiew guten Morgen
guten Morgen nach der Rückeroberung des
strategisch wichtigen Ortes Liman im
Osten scheint es auch an der sogenannten
Carson Front im Süden Erfolge zu geben
jedenfalls wird das in den einschlägigen
Medien und Blogs berichtet was wissen
sie darüber
Präsident selenski hat das bestätigt das
handelt sich um zwei Siedlungen im Süden
und das ist insofern ein interessantes
und wichtiges Detail wenn wir erinnern
uns als die Ukraine bekannt gegeben hat
eine Offensive zu starten da ging es vor
allem um den Süden da ging es vor allem
um die Region ich habe Zorn dass dann
die Geländegewinne im Nordosten kamen im
Osten kamen das war für viele Beobachter
überraschend insofern zeigt dieser
Gelände Gewinn dieser zwei kleinen
Siedlungen jetzt dass die Offensive
nicht nur im Osten andauert sondern eben
auch im Süden diese Offensive im Osten
mit diesem militärischen aber
zweifelsohne auch politischen Erfolg der
Rückeroberung von Liman was hören Sie
wie geht das jetzt weiter wir gehen die
Ukrainer militärisch vor versucht man
jetzt weiter vorzustoßen oder wenn man
jetzt erst versuchen die Stellungen die
erobert wurden zu sichern
die Informationen die wir aus
Regierungskreisen bekommen sagen ganz
klar dass der weitere Vorstoß der Plan
ist das bedeutet aber nicht dass jetzt
in einem ähnlichen Tempo vorgegangen
wird wie wir das Anfang September
beobachtet haben als in der Region
harikif mehr als 6000 Quadratkilometer
zurückerobert worden sind
selensky gab ja gestern bekannt dass
Lehmann vollständig befreit ist diese
Stadt ist zu großen Teilen vermiet das
heißt da steht den ukrainischen Soldaten
noch sehr viel Arbeit bevor den Behörden
die dort derzeit tätig sind und dadurch
dass das ja ein wichtiger Knotenpunkt
war ist das erstmal ein massiver Schlag
der das russische Militär deutlich
trifft es ist aber davon auszugehen dass
die Offensive sich auch dort im Osten
weiter vorsetzt beispielsweise Richtung
Region Johannes nun haben wir ja vorhin
schon verteilungsministerin Lambrecht
gesehen und gehört sie war ja am Samstag
in Odessa und damit zum ersten Mal seit
Kriegsbeginn in der alleine sie hat auch
Waffenlieferungen zugesagt aber schützen
oder gar Panzer Kampfpanzer zum Beispiel
Leopard oder ähnliches Material gibt es
nicht daran hat sie keinen Zweifel
gelassen und wenn überhaupt dann noch
nur in Abstimmung mit anderen wie ist
denn dieser Besuch in Kiew aufgenommen
worden wird die deutsche Unterstützung
gewürdigt oder immer noch als zu gering
angesehen
ich würde sagen sowohl als auch es wird
gewürdigt dass Deutschland unterstützt
das wird gesehen auf verschiedenen
Ebenen nicht nur die militärische
Unterstützung auch die humanitäre
Unterstützung auch die Unterstützung der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer die derzeit
in Deutschland sind das Frau Lambrecht
jetzt ihres Tee zugesichert hat was ja
schon im Juni zugesichert wurde aber die
Ministerin hat ja jetzt zugesagt dass
dieses
Luftabwehrsystem in wenigen Tagen in der
Ukraine ankommen soll das wird eindeutig
gewürdig das hat auch ihr Amtskollege
olexie resnikow bestätigt aber und das
ist eben der zentrale Punkt das hören
wir auch aus Regierungskreisen die
Ukraine verstehen teilweise nicht oder
haben das Gefühl dass Deutschland die
militärische Situation nicht versteht es
gibt ein großes Unverständnis dafür dass
Leopard 2 Panzer dass diese benötigten
Kampfpanzer aus ukrainischer Sicht nicht
geliefert werden und die gesamte
Argumentation mit dem Ringtausch die
Deutschland immer wieder hervorhebt die
wird hier auch nicht sonder
ja wahrgenommen oder wird anders gesehen
also es gibt eine unterschiedliche
Perspektive ähnlich übrigens wie die auf
den NATO-Beitritt da wünscht sich die
Ukraine größere Unterstützung oder klare
Unterstützung aus Deutschland ich sage
vielen Dank für diese Erläuterung und
danke für Ihre Zeit